what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves
and my sincere hope is that if you
believe in yourself as much as I believe
in you you'll be able to change the
planet so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn 9 surprising
facts about Will Smith
[Music]
[ __ ] number one he believes he can
become president of the United States if
he wanted to a few months ago I said
that I believe that if I chose to I
could be the president of the United
States and I think as I've had a chance
to intellectualize why I said them and I
think that there's a certain delusional
quality that all successful people have
to have you have to believe that
something different than what has
happened for the last 52 Iligan 10 years
of history you have to believe that
something different can happen and I say
you to my friends all the time and we
laugh about it I truly honestly as I sit
here before you right now as honestly as
I can say to you I truly believe that I
could be the president if I wanted to
and as bizarre as that may sound to
people that have traveled the path
before me and to people who actually
know how difficult it is foolish Will
Smith honestly believes it's Bach number
two he knows how to solve the Rubik's
Cube really quickly
one minute
[Music]
maybe you pretend to be just takes a
minute it just takes a minute
[Music]
[Applause]
fact number three he's part owner of the
Philadelphia 76ers basketball team there
is nothing like in Olive entertainment
than to walk into the building when it's
announced that you're a part owner of
your hometown basketball candy like that
is ridiculous I mean if the team doesn't
win it sucks later that first initial
fact number four he was the first
hip-hop artist to be nominated for an
Academy Award and you would normally you
know what a great mom best actor but I
read somewhere that you can't because
you lost it - Denzel Washington thing
well no you don't Lucy well you didn't
win it did you take it home you it is
you don't lose an Oscar once you you're
I'm still the Academy Award nominee you
Will Smith we're all winners no no no
that's what they said it to Oscar lunch
it says it over okay says you're all
already winners okay you weren't there
Jonathan
so we'll which of your fellow winners
got to turn to the Wold home dude that
was for which one was that for it was a
training day
great film yes fantastic film but I read
somewhere that you weren't you kind of I
don't know whether you you said you
didn't feel ready or sometimes you you
maybe you thought this wasn't your time
yet when you can get nominated you get
invited to the party it's huge I think
you know but I can I can always tell
when things aren't right for me in my
life at that time I didn't feel like
that was the time you know but acting
for pursuit of happiness I actually felt
like that was the time and I still deal
with he didn't win it what we were
always
you know but it really is one of those
awards is so it's like the show is so
huge the concept of it is so huge it's
wonderful to be to be invited to the Big
Dance
[ __ ] number five he first met his
wife-to-be Jada pinkett-smith when she
auditioned to be his girlfriend on the
Fresh Prince of bel-air you mentioned
well who everybody knows who will Smith
is but I heard you auditioned for Fresh
Prince - I did as his profession does
his girlfriend I'll never forget it's
funny because he was there and that must
have been his thing you know
coming into the casting calls you know
young girls so he's you know out in the
hall so I walk in and you know the
casting director she looks at me and she
says you know I'm doing my line since
you said you know what you just you're
just too short for well but thank you
for coming in and I was like all right
[Laughter]
so I walked out you know and we'll was
like hey shorty let me talk to you about
right hey not fast to talk about home
you ain't got a role for me but then
over the years you know he finally yeah
I did a different world and then I did a
couple of movies and then he want to
come you know four seas and fifth seas
and asking me to be his girlfriend again
he came down the winston-salem while I
was doing a movie called inkwell oh yeah
and he was like you know will you come
and be a serious regular on Fresh Prince
and at that time I was like I'm not
trying to do television right now and
I'm glad that I said no because we
probably wouldn't be married now [ __ ]
number six the film he most regrets
making is wild wild west it's too bad I
really liked that movie have you failed
in the last four five years ten years um
you consider anything you've done a
failure yes absolutely like certain
things because a movie didn't gross as
much as that failure though actually
they'd be to converse with wild wild
west yeah it felt like a failure because
the the film wasn't great right you know
but did 225 million will smith is not I
was like oh it hurts so bad you know it
felt like it felt like I got what I
wanted out of the deal but my fans
didn't get their half of the deal fact
number seven he's the first rapper to
win a Grammy Award and I kind of forget
sometimes because I think of you as a
movie star movie actor first and
foremost I forget of course is huge
square beforehand this big successful
career as a rapper yeah
did you and you were the first lap
packed I believe to win the Grammy yep
ever won a Grammy eighty-eight no one
take that away
fact number 8 he speaks fluent Spanish
I'm fluent in Spanish hola mucho gusto
I'm fluent in French just we desolated
met by autograph I'm fluent in Japanese
konnichiwa Dom arigato gozaimashita do
you think what's a Spanish mmm that
would be correct
will Latinos porque el mundo debería
Rivera after earth oh okay la película
basada mil años en el futuro e tengo
miedo por que necesito practicar mass me
español para la película tiene accion
the effect of specialis pero la película
stay on Padre either hee ho como se
dicen sobre to survive so brevity Elsie
gracias
and fact number nine he was chosen by
People magazine as one of the 50 most
beautiful people in the world when I go
to theaters when my movies come out and
I sit in the back and I try to see how
people are reacting and there was a
scene in bad boys and I was running with
my shirt open it was the first time in
my life ever I heard a woman go in I was
like I didn't know what to do I was like
what was that miss but it really is a
it's a this is a strange thing to be to
be considered like when I think sex I
look at Denzel and I was like now that's
a sexy man but I just never thought of
myself in that way so it's fun so thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know which of the
facts were new to you or surprise to you
do you hope that Will Smith one day runs
for president I'd love to get your
thoughts leave it down in the comments
below thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one or it is much love
I'll see you soon